I own a Lamborghini Thank You president  Trump I'm a big baller and a controlling  father I wish they would disappear I  wish they would all just disappear the  ball then Teddy Lithuania for Christmas  vacation I got everything  my big baller hat big baller butt-wipes  big baller birth control big buck wait a  minute  what are though I made them disappear I  made my family disappear this Johnny  Patrick we know you're in there  look I'm up here jerks come and get me  let's get him this is it don't get  scared now  [Music]  welcome to the league youngster those  traps and home alone we're [ __ ] bozo  dad hey levar you want your kid back hey  guys what's going on you know what I'll  just take big ball of Kyle good man son  y'all have yourself a wonderful  Christmas now cuz big baller will  [Music]